The complex conjugate of 2 minus 3i is just two plus 3i. Once again, we just
look at the sign of the coefficient b over here, the coefficient of the
imaginary part of the number and we flip it. It was negative and now it's
positive. Let's look then at the graphical relationship between complex
conjugates. The two orange points here are one pair of conjugates, 3 plus 4i and
3 minus 4i. And the teal points are another pair, 2 plus 3i and 2 minus 3i. What
we notice is that the horizontal coordinate of either point in each pair is the
same. But the vertical coordinate is just flipped so each point is just a
reflection of the point it matches with across the real axis. If we have the
number negative 8 minus 4i, then its conjugate must be the point that has the
same horizontal coordinate and the opposite vertical coordinate, so it will be
this negative 8 plus 4i which does seem to be correct.